[Music]
on this Friday night federal cash for
cripples oil companies our goal is to
create immediate jobs how much help is
coming and why this isn't a bailout DC's
goal to crush the curve the new optimism
and how soon restrictions could be
relaxed attention all passengers the new
rule on the way for all travelers and we
have and the Space Odyssey that went
awry we do we are deep trouble the 50th
anniversary of Apollo 13s near disaster
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
reporting tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us Canada's hard-hit oil and
gas sector is getting a badly needed
boost one that will help companies and
workers there have been repeated
requests for aid because of Kovan 19 and
a huge dip in global oil prices now the
federal government is spending 1.7
billion dollars to clean up abandoned
oil wells in Alberta Saskatchewan and BC
Ottawa is also creating a 750 million
dollar fund to cut methane emissions
there's also help for businesses 962
million to help those who don't have
access to traditional financial
institutions the Liberals say the aid
will save about 10,000 jobs across the
country our goal is to create immediate
jobs in these provinces while helping
companies avoid bankruptcy and
supporting our environmental targets but
will it be enough to get the economy
back on track
Abigail Beeman has our top story tonight
punched twice by record low oil prices
and kovat 19 Alberta has been waiting
weeks for help for the oil and gas
industry now they have some we've also
heard very clearly and not just from
industry but from municipalities
particularly rural municipalities
landowners across Alberta that the issue
of persistent orphan or inactive wealth
is a real challenge 1.7 billion dollars
to clean up orphaned wells not just in
Alberta but also Saskatchewan and
British Columbia and three-quarters of a
billion dollars for an emission
reduction fund that focuses on methane
10% of an earmarked for Newfoundland and
Labrador so this is you know really
important for small to medium sized
businesses I think there's a perception
that the industry is dominated by
massive capital projects big oil rigs
miles of pipeline and in fact it's
dominated by small to medium sized
businesses one of them paedo exploration
and development disappointing woefully
inadequate would be terms that I would
use to describe what they're offering
to the industry particularly considering
what the industry is going through right
now
many hoping for a bigger oil bailout
what the industry I think was really
looking for was a package liquidity to
help bridge the time between now as we
face these really low prices and when
all of us as consumers around the world
start to get back out and drive and fly
and demand for oil goes back up cleaning
things up while getting back to work is
in line with the Trudeau government's
political goals you know their old
refrain the economy and the environment
go hand in hand just because we're in a
health crisis doesn't mean we can
neglect the environmental crisis
Alberta's premier says today's health is
critical and immediately tweeted his
thanks but Jason Kenney is clear more
needs to be done I went once to a once
again reiterate the urgency of the
national government stepping up to
ensure liquidity this was the first
announcement about help for the oil and
gas industry but a government source
says it won't be the last this will be a
multi step approach like so many of the
financial health announcements have been
these past weeks
abigail Beeman at Global News Ottawa our
David Egan joins us now David the
funding certainly helps but will it go
far enough
well Westerners tell me it's a start but
more is going to need to be done the big
deal here is that these two federal
agencies Business Development Canada and
Export Development Canada they're going
to get involved helping mid-sized energy
firms who right now have a liquidity
crisis they can't get credit from their
banks can't borrow
now if the BDC and the EDC do their jobs
right that could mean billions for the
sector and it could save a lot of firms
from going bankrupt Robin
all right what about politics how much
is that a factor in all of this well a
fair bit but you know what it's not the
Jason County versus Justin Trudeau kind
of politics it's really internal liberal
politics there's a whole lot of Liberal
MPs and some liberal cabinet ministers
heritage Minister Stephen Gebo for
example who are dead set against the
idea of a federal bailout of the oil and
gas sector so the political problem for
the Prime Minister is does
a package to address the liquidity
crisis for a range of sectors say
manufacturing tourism airlines and oh by
the way the oil and gas sector in the
meantime the Canadian Association of
Petroleum Producers is asking the
federal government to temporarily
relieve oil producers of what they call
some low risk regulatory requirements
things like pollution monitoring or
testing water quality now
environmentalists say this is just the
oil lobby trying to get out from
underneath regulatory requirements that
it has long complained about and just
using the Cova 19 crisis as the excuse
Robin
David Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
Trudeau also announced 500 million
dollars in support for Canada's arts
culture and sports sectors which have
been hit particularly hard by the
pandemic there are some glimmers of hope
in Canada's fight against Cova 19 dr.
Teresa Tam says there are signs the
virus is slowing in parts of the country
but that progress could easily be lost
if Canadians stopped physical distancing
new outbreaks can be sparked anywhere at
any time so remember this is not a
sprint it is a marathon and there will
only be unpleasant surprises if we quit
early more than 1,300 people in Canada
have died of Kovan 19 and the number of
confirmed cases has now surpassed 31,000
Ontario recorded its most new cases in a
single day 564 more people have tested
positive Quebec also reported a spike
941 new confirmed cases Alberta has 239
new ones ABC has only 43 new cases and
if that trend continues BC officials say
they could start easing restrictions in
mid-may Erik Sorenson looks at what BC
is getting right and how other provinces
compare it is on balance good news for
BC the upward curve in the number of
kovat 19 cases is flattening and the
requirement for ICUs and ventilators is
well within BC's capacity to handle the
outbreak so far modeled against other
jurisdictions the number of cases in
northern Italy and in Hebei China
see the purple line is by comparison
much lower day by day and not very
different from the much admired outcome
so far in South Korea so we are on the
right track but we must hold that line
PC's data shows something striking about
the age groups with the virus the number
of kovat 19 cases has mostly struck
working age adults in their 30s to their
60s but the number of deaths has taken a
terrible toll on older people in fact
the median age of people who have died
is 86 in British Columbia this again
reflects the tragedy that has been the
hit the outbreaks that we've had in our
long-term care homes here in British
Columbia and it reflects the rise in
mortality among the elderly across the
country the regional disparity we saw in
the wave of cases we're now seeing in
the number of deaths with the smaller
provinces the numbers remain very low on
the prairies the East Coast the northern
territories barely 1% of the total
deaths in the country now in the bigger
provinces BC and Alberta have seen a
drop-off in their numbers it is a much
bigger number in Ontario and a
disturbingly high number in Quebec and
this represents 98 percent of all the
deaths in Canada but here is the trend
over the last week Ontario and Quebec
together account for 94 percent of the
deaths in the country all the other
provinces and territories just six
percent and the sad fact is Quebec has
recorded almost 62 percent of all the
deaths in Canada in the last week the
tragedy in Quebec has played out largely
in long-term care facilities and the
province is struggling to get on top of
it we're going to a tough situation but
we're doing everything we can to take
care of our elderly a surge in kovat 19
deaths was expected this month it is
hitting harder in central Canada but the
advice to all of Canada is don't let up
keep your distance we have come through
this together but we're not out of it
yet we're still in the eye of that storm
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto a
personal support worker at a Toronto
long-term care home has died from Cova
1954 old Christine manda garyun
passed away Wednesday she worked in
health care for more than three decades
most recently at Siena Altamont care
community her husband believes more
should have been done to protect them
and his wife there are more than 40
confirmed cases of kovin 19 at the
Toronto facility at least eight
residents have died from the virus the
federal government is sending
reinforcements into Quebec to help long
term care homes hit by outbreaks 125
military medical personnel will be
deployed starting this weekend at least
688 people in Quebec have died of copán
19 more than half were in long-term care
homes in many cases those facilities are
understaffed and workers are poorly paid
who ex-premier admitted today that
staffing problems played a role in the
crisis he said in French that he should
have acted faster if I were to do it
again I would have increased the wages
of orderlies more quickly I take full
responsibility for this we came into
this crisis badly equipped and of course
the situation has deteriorated the
deaths of Canadians that care homes are
raising fears about how many seniors
could contract Cova 19 Europe has seen a
rapid surge and similar tragedies in
these facilities only now our
governments they're changing how they
deal with these vulnerable residents and
staff here's Redman Shannon three weeks
ago was Spain's death rate was rising
rapidly soldiers found dead bodies
abandoned inside in Madrid nursing home
staff had apparently been overwhelmed
the virus swept through Italian care
homes just as quickly most countries had
restricted or banned outside visitors
but in many cases hospital patients were
admitted into care homes without testing
the UK is now changing that in a
similar move to provinces like Ontario
today we can announce that everybody
going from hospital into social care
will be tested will be isolated whilst
the result of that test comes through
staff and residents with symptoms will
be tested too it should help reduce
infections but it might also impact the
UK's death numbers which only includes
those who died inside hospitals I think
there are growing numbers of deaths
within care homes and we're very anxious
that we get those properly and
accurately recorded so that we can
ensure that we understand how to manage
this pandemic this week it emerged the
UK death toll figure including care
homes is at least 15 percent higher than
government tallies Belgium's very high
national death rate could be down to it
including suspected and untested cases
of kovat 19 in care facilities like
Canada almost half of its deaths could
be in seniors homes suggesting the UK
and others could still be under
estimating deaths Italy only started
testing in care homes last week Britain
meanwhile is putting in place protocols
for families to visit dying relatives
giving people the chance to say goodbye
helping if nothing else to make the most
difficult moments a little easier Redman
Shannon Global News London air travelers
are facing a new rule coming up what
else you need to bring to the airport
if you plan on catching a flight any
time soon you'll want to pack a mask
starting Monday all air passengers in
Canada need to have a non-medical mask
to cover their mouth and nose during
travel you'll be required to prove you
have it during the boarding process
otherwise you won't be allowed on the
plane people traveling on ferries are
also being encouraged to wear
non-medical mass whenever possible in
the u.s. plans to reopen businesses and
restart the economy are going nowhere
fast officials in many states say they
don't have the testing ability needed to
let people get back to regular life and
as Jackson prosecco explains that caused
President Donald Trump to lash out for
all the talk of reopening the US economy
most of America is nowhere close to
ready in South Dakota more than 600
workers at a meat processing plant have
kovat 19 the plant which handles 5% of
u.s. pork is closed indefinitely New
York has seen more than 600 fatalities
in the last day we're recommending
certain things they'll be in place
dependent on what the governor wants to
do Thursday President Donald Trump
revealed guidelines for how the states
should lift stay at home orders slowly
over time by Friday he was lashing out
at governors over Twitter demanding they
open up immediately he's doing nothing
he said it's up to the states it's up to
the governors which is what it always
was governors and the experts agree the
US has fallen short when it comes to
kovat 19 testing warning that makes it
impossible to return to regular life you
do need testing because we need to know
what actually is happening in our
communities the materials needed to
conduct the tests remain in short supply
the governor's wanted national strategy
but Trump has told States to do it by
themselves
just days after claiming he himself has
absolute authority I think the president
doesn't want to believe that testing is
a problem and it is a problem
particularly if we want to get the
country going again amidst all the
back-and-forth a mayor
kids keep getting sick the nation's
capital Washington is quickly emerging
as a new hotspot school has been
canceled for the rest of the year
just as in New York officials are
turning convention centers into field
hospitals tonight as the u.s. approaches
700,000 confirmed cases of kovat 19 some
local officials are in fact opening
things up in Texas they're going to
allow all retailers to open up to serve
customers on a to-go basis Minnesota is
opening in golf courses and in Florida
in Jacksonville they've opened the
beaches and tonight they're already
packed
Robin Jackson Prosecco and Washington
president Trump's former lawyer is set
to be released from jail early because
of the pandemic Michael Cohen will serve
the rest of his three-year sentence at
home he pleaded guilty to several
charges including campaign finance fraud
and lying to Congress white helmets
white knights still ahead how a group of
Syrians plans to protect refugees from
kovat 19
China has dramatically raised its death
toll in Wuhan where the new corona virus
was first detected the number shot up 50
percent from twelve hundred and ninety
to thirty eight hundred and sixty nine
officials facing claims of a cover-up
are blaming incorrect reporting and
delays it's the first time China is
publicly admitting fatalities were
omitted including those who died at home
a new United Nations report is sounding
the alarm about the devastation covin 19
could cause in Africa
it shows 300,000 people could die from
the virus this year even under the
best-case scenario with no interventions
Africa could see more than 3 million
deaths and over a billion people
infected with Kovan 19 the UN says
poverty crowded urban areas and
widespread health problems make Africa
particularly susceptible to the virus so
far there are more than 18,000 confirmed
cases and at least 970 deaths but the
continent is weeks behind Europe in the
pandemic various humanitarian rescue
group the white helmets is disinfecting
camps where people fleeing conflict are
being forced to live with little
supplies in a series of tweets the white
helmet says its volunteers have started
a sterilization program to reach as many
internationally displaced residents as
it can with the focus being on virus
defense and education a large number of
hospitals were destroyed in raids by the
Syrian government and Russia Apollo 13s
going on 50 up next the anniversary of a
disastrous miracle
and certain recovery forces are working
to extract the crew from the capsule a
three-person crew from the International
Space Station returned to Earth today a
very different planet than the one they
left more than 200 days ago
the two Americans and one Russian were
met by team wearing masks and gloves the
precautions during this pandemic fifty
years ago today the world was gripped by
another group of astronauts returning to
Earth NASA's Apollo 13 mission to the
moon had taken a dangerous turn an
explosion in space the journey turned
into a fight for survival and with the
help of Canadians and Americans back on
the ground it was eventually labeled a
successful failure Mike Armstrong
explains what no one knew when Apollo 13
lifted off the launch pad is that one of
its liquid oxygen tanks was damaged it
was like a bomb waiting to go off I had
gotten letters before the flight about
the number 13 being unlucky I was not
superstitious didn't think much of it
but I probably should have know the
mission was almost flawless for two days
the crew had just done this TV broadcast
it was just one more thing to do for the
day mix the oxygen tanks with that
explosion the mission changed from the
moon to survival we do we are in deep
trouble we didn't know how deep the
trouble was the late report says the
spacecraft now is operating on battery
power alone with the world watching NASA
scrambled reworking everything the
astronauts life support was running out
and ground control had to figure out a
way to bring them back one of the
maneuvers was to recalculate this swing
around the moon using thrust from what
was supposed to be the engine used to
land now there was a Canadian
contribution a team at the University of
Toronto was asked to figure out the
pressure it would take to separate the
lunar and crew modules just before
reentry three members of the group were
honored for the 40th anniversary and
remembered their deadline they were
given just four hours
we've never had time really to be to
thinking of what if we gave the wrong
advice and it failed okay Larry
yeah it was one of those moments where
the world stopped in solidarity even the
Soviet Union had offered help in the end
it was almost a perfect landing the
legacy of Apollo 13 is worth taking a
positive attitude as the crew did and
people at Mission Control turned an
almost certain catastrophe into a
successful recovery wagon and Fred hey
none of the three astronauts ever had
another moon mission but none of them
ever considered Apollo 13 anything but a
success Mike Armstrong global news and
that is global national for this Friday
I'm Robin Gill this year also marks the
50th anniversary of some of the world's
first pride parades those celebrations
may be canceled so tonight we leave you
with Canadian showing their pride at
home in these isolated times mental
health takes a toll
so the hashtag pride at home is helping
the community connect thank you for
watching and I'll see you back here
tomorrow good night
[Music]
[Applause]
you